Good morning, Héctor Mejía greets you with the
information clock for today, Thursday, March 18,
starting next week,
Nevadans over the age of 16 with
pre-existing health conditions
will now be able to receive the vaccine against
the corona virus and then starting
on April 5  everyone over 16 years of age
will be
eligible governor steel alone said that in
nevada thousands of people are being vaccinated
per day and that the state receives
about 65 thousand doses per week this
indicates that the state will soon be able to
open completely to improve  the economy
and if you still do not know where to get the vaccine
there are several places to receive it
this includes the word hotel the
las vegas convention center the cast
maintain the southern nevada health district
and some pharmacies and days for
more details remember from  visit
einstein dotcom diagonal en español
in other news sprints preserve
reopen your outdoor space
tomorrow this includes  hey the
botanical garden the animal habitat and its
trails its hours are from Friday to
Monday from 9 in the morning to 4 in the afternoon
and now we are going to the
weather forecast we will have high temperatures
around 70 for today the wind will return
for tomorrow but  The weather will still be
warm. Have a nice day. I'm
Héctor Mejía and this was your short
isea newsletter in Spanish.